we're about to brush our teeth so much
right now are you what the funny thing
is I was about to film
I wouldn't brush my teeth hi I'm destiny
hi I'm Mitch and today we're testing out
cheap versus expensive toothpaste well I
mean how how hard could it be to get to
face anyways I mean like you're kinda
you can kind of tell I just had lunch
can I taste it oh right
hey oh we have fireflies we have two
Disney Princesses for two Disney
Princesses hey now boom that's you
believe to match my dress my favorite
color is blue that's okay okay yeah I
got Cinderella
you were the whatever that's your
princess I stopped calling you a
princess and went over all right
[Music]
lucky number two this is the second
expect most expensive one
what it just doesn't look good there's a
rush away
my test is a little different oh yeah
this is the cheap I want the speed but
it's not too phony Ireland
oh cool guys oh the cheap stuff thumbs
up like bubble bath enemies our daughter
would Colgate we're now not laying in
cold wait I thought its pokey it's not
what's the messy video
I just swapped them I'm supposed to go
oh okay
why would you do that I didn't think to
be honest I forgot to spit it out okay
I can't guarantee brands but I can say
that I do think that that one is cheap I
said it's the most expensive one I'm
gonna stick with it I still think this
is number two so for this one I'm
thinking cheap cheap definitely change
we agreed so now we got the the blue one
with the minty stripes oh look at all
that blue dye number two hey how many
teeth does it take to make a tube of
toothpaste
what a toothpaste
teeth spoon sorry I said that wrong what
is wrong with you all right let's do the
lift test Oh No what are you doing
[Music]
she's ranking guys you reckon this is
definitely cheap but like oh it tastes
like paint do you taste them I think
this one is definitely cheaper than that
one now I'll get a bad aftertaste
partner finish yeah you got it you
finally reached you it lingers ooh I
think this one is more expensive than
the first one that we tried just because
you think the other way and I don't want
to agree with you
last up we have the black toothpaste the
toothpaste for the ridge this is what
like the rich pen is what people in LA
is Wall Street they probably don't brush
their teeth this is really doesn't it
smells like is it taste bad okay this is
like tar um that's the only thing I can
think that might it kind of looks like
Halloween makeup wow that's a very
specific very specific why are you doing
that why are you doing how often you get
the opportunity that his black face if
you won't pull out your wallet and spend
their money you too can use white people
commercial well that is some black spit
man that's nasty this one really cool
let's be honest though is that your love
of the color black that's all I'm just
gonna say like I think I just like the
fact that it was black it was scary at
first I'm not gonna lie I was a little
alarmed feel like now that's gone I just
feel really good on my teeth everyday
right you're gonna say that that one was
expensive I think that this one's
expensive I think this one's in the
middle I still think it's the most
expensive I'm still going second most
but it was definitely different
I think this one is the most expensive I
think it's the cheapest I think this is
the second most expensive for sure I
actually think it's the most expensive
okay so I think this one is the cheapest
I think this is middle cheapest chambers
BAM oh my god I was right all along the
black one second most expensive I'm just
saying I'm so good at this job a little
light there yeah I'm just shocked that
like you're one for three years
yeah she lost I totally like Blake won I
lost as long as she can we made it
toothpaste is toothpaste this is where
you came from this is where you're going
this is we want to be visible don't know
where you
[Music]
you